okay well hi everyone in David and Karen
a film courage here we are on the line
with Katie Graham and andrew matthews
writers and directors of the film zero
charisma which currently has eight days
left in its crowdfunding campaign on
IndieGoGo and zero charisma is about
scott white amir and over room game
basically whose life is in disarray he
has a menial job at a donut shop he
lives with an abusive grandmother but
what kind of holds everything together
is his love for Dungeons and Dragons D&D
and that introduces him to a new cast of
characters and all sorts of politics
that go along with that yeah I mean you
mentioned IndieGoGo campaign their goal
their target was fifteen thousand
dollars and now they're they're over
23,000 they stove 88 days left in the
campaign so this is this is quite an
accomplishment for indy gogo yeah it
sure is and you may also remember Katie
and Andrew from one of my favorite films
best worst movie it's a doc about the
making of what has been touted as
possibly one of the worst films ever
troll 2 and it's from the year nineteen
ninety Katie was the DP and co-editor on
the film and Andrew was the lead editor
so welcome yes thank you both for
joining us today you know what yep I
think it's great yeah thanks for having
us you know and then look yes it looks
it looks beautiful they're comfortable
you know yeah and we especially
appreciate you taking time out here man
you know they you know sort of delaying
the BBQ plans that just to spend on you
no time to chat with us um and we know
that you guys are in in austin texas you
know you move there a year and a half
ago why are we seeing so many talented
filmmakers in this city of austin i I
can only speak for us I guess and it was
um the also attracted us as a place to
make independent films because of the
small but supportive film community and
also the cost I mean the teaser trailer
that we made for zero charisma we got to
use some awesome locations in the game
shops the comic book shops and and we
just walked in and said hey we talked to
a manager would you mind if we shot here
some day and there's they said oh yeah
sure come on back home it's too early
for you you know and and you do that in
Los Angeles and they say yeah it's
thousand dollars day you know here's our
forum directory there's our fee
structure and so there's just it's a
it's a kind of town where it's small
enough that that kind of think it
happened but it's big enough where you
have a lot of talent and you have all of
the you know the know-how and the art
artistry it's just it's just such a film
community here there's a there's a
community in Austin just being a city
and then there's a film community here
that's a real community that Los Angeles
you know it just there's so many people
then it can't really be a community like
this so I think that's the benefit for
sure and what dress is awesome now with
as your charisma and with best worst
movie you sort of spot like these two
themes about underground cultures and
people that are fanatics of these
cultures what is it about that that
attracts you I mean why I mean you with
zero charisma here you have this guy
that loves dungeons and dragons and then
with best worst movie you have these
people that love troll to they buy
merchandise 20 years after the fact and
and follow the movie around the US what
is it about these subcultures that
you're attracted to I don't I don't I
don't think we set up intentionally to
to examine subcultures I I guess it's
just a comes from wanting to make films
about specifics you don't want you know
sort of ordinary generalities you want
your people who are very specific and
unique and I think it's just more the
times I mean with the way things are
going with the internet and everything
it's like everybody belongs to a
subculture you know there's no there's
no there's nobody anymore who doesn't
have some kind of subculture so in a way
and you get to know a character then
you're getting to know subculture they
they belong to and they're both things I
mean I was a dnd player for
you know but a deity player for a long
time and we were both big troll two fans
so in a way it's just because we were
members of those subcultures yeah yeah
we've gotten the Peaceville yeah yeah
and Katie are you also a fan of Dungeons
& Dragons I am not really a fan of
dungeon dragon I'm interested in nerd
culture um I'm a nerd in some respects
regarding certain things and say I'm
kind of a comedy nerd I yeah I make
vlogs on youtube so I'm kind of video
nerd kinda cable access and stuff like
that um so I don't know um but yeah D&D
specifically that that's kind of Andrews
Everest not been able to get her to play
I I don't know but I'm totally
interested in it I mean not really the
game but the people it draws too much
man yeah so much bad and how did you
formulate Scott's character because here
is a nerd but he's not like the week
nerd in Revenge of the Nerds where you
want to protect him and he's not at the
charming leading man where did you come
up with this sort of composite I think
there are there are you know examples of
that type of character and a lot of them
in you look like The Simpsons comic book
guy yeah he's kind of that time I Alma
know-it-all nerd know where it's always
trumping you always knowing more than
you about everything um yeah that seems
to be more the kind of there and I don't
want to I don't want anyone to think
that using the word nerd disparaging it
you know oh yeah we're certainly nerds
ourselves do you got a faction it but
but that's more the week kind of nerd
it's almost not as common it doesn't
seem to me it's more about like knowing
more than you and always out doing you
and yeah I know more about this subject
than anybody else that you've guarded
yeah and we mo I love we've always loved
those characters from there's the no
fears in the UK office and there's that
did that character who only had one
appearance he was the tech guy who comes
to like fix the computers and he has
that conversation with Garrett and it's
just like this amazing character he's
there for one second it's like that's
yeah I need to know everything about
everything and it's like I think
everybody knows that type of guy you
don't know man they everybody knows that
so we were just like let's go let's make
you know they're kind of sick of sitting
like an independent movies really hip
cool young people I can't you know the
feeling of wanting to see you know the
type of person that most people don't
want to make a movie about you know I
mean that to me that's kind of what
independent movies really should be you
know and I think the most important
thing for comedy is a real passion you
have a character who's extremely
motivated and passionate and and speaks
his mind yes turn up that's committed
yeah and what's the reason or where did
you formulate sort of the story
structure here it is Scott's sort of
vying for attention amongst the Nerds um
against this guy miles is that right
who's sort of this new golden boy that's
come in and and sort of attracted that
respect of the school dnd group so where
did you formulate this story um you know
Scott's living with an abusive
grandmother he's got a grunt job that he
hates I think it's some pretty classic
storyline we actually as we can't with
the idea we started watching renting
movies that had great rivalries in them
you know the sort of I guess you'd call
and what you know it's funny we went
with them and saw bridesmaids the other
night which is really really funny and
we're like oh gosh this is very kind of
similar story story yeah and it's you
know somebody a new character who comes
into someone's the main characters world
and threatens something very dear to
them but for one reason or another but
really no socially socially threat right
it's not like they're actually doing
anything right reten them it's just
their presence is socially a prep right
and for one reason or another like open
conflict is not an option so I have to
find out there goes our screen so they
have to find ways to like battle this
person's you know and so socially
acceptable ways this just seems funny to
us yeah and you seem to be getting
comments from people on like you know
discuss or whatever
people that kind of feel a kinship with
this character Scott where they're like
finally someone you know showing sort of
the nerd as the as the hero and you're
gathering people that are sort of real
life introverts they kind of feel their
triumphing over the the hipsters that
come in and make a fad popular for a
while and then abandon it so what kind
of support have you received as far as
people giving you feedback about how
they feel a real connection to this
story I don't know I mean I just I'm
blown away by peoplesupport of it i mean
you know i mean just the indiegogo thing
alone that where you know almost ten
thousand dollars packs are cool I mean I
can't even I would we can't even believe
it I it's really really surprising to us
i mean the day we put up the indiegogo
campaign i thought oh god we're only
gonna get when we gonna do how we're
going to get this money we're never
going to make the skull yeah and i just
and just roll then it was just amazing
you know facebook week you know so much
interest on facebook I just it's kind of
a surprise to us I mean we knew we
wanted to see it but I it's amazing
other people won't see it too there were
fears from beginning some people who
would hear the concept or something
would say people don't want to see
movies about losers they want they want
movies about you know strong people
about good-looking people yeah i mean
you surprising that somebody would say
that but they would you know and and and
what we really believed like no there's
there's a there's a big you know opening
for characters that are not cool and not
don't have it together or not him and
and i think we are kind of it was ben
validating the house of an action that
we've had that people do want to see it
here they can identify with oh yeah um
let's just switch to best worst movie
for a moment i'm curious how did the
stars of troll to react to people making
such a huge fuss over them 20 years
after the fact and almost from like a
negative standpoint where it was touted
as it would had like the worst IMDB
rating or something like that and here
they're being sort of praised for that
how did how did they react once the
cameras were off or while they were
rolling
hi it's pretty much the same I mean I
think I think they didn't really
understand it you know um but then they
were like but it felt good you know and
people really at these screenings they
really did even though they don't think
these people are great actors they
really do love them in a way like as if
it as a famous person I mean they really
treated them like stars and it's just
something these people never experience
them alive so I mean it was as touching
to them really I mean that you know it
was yeah and there were some that had
suspicions not sure about it you know
but we didn't want to be made fun of
right and you know fair enough funny I
would understand that too and then some
of them were saying like I want me to do
with it and then once it got to a
certain level popularity then they're
like well maybe I can use this to
promote my things that I'm doing I'm
sure it's like it and I know it roll to
Michael weights who was but the father
played by George Hardy who's actually a
dentist in Alabama um it's kind of
strange how that happened cuz it seems
like he was an actor for a while then
maybe had the dentistry that he followed
and then he sort of had this resurgence
won some best worst movie came out I
know NPR interviewed him and seems to be
getting a lot of press what's George up
to now I think he still his dentistry
his daughter just graduated high school
and I think um you know they're about to
put her through college and you know so
he's still a dentist I think he's the
documentary was pretty accurate in that
respect as how George's story and he was
really like sick of the troll to crap
and he wanted to just go back to its his
life and on but with that same like you
know Effie there was an opportunity to
you know Billy on television again he'd
take it a second yeah you know we wanted
to touch on the best worst movie to give
ourselves the opportunity to find out
how did that film sort of influence your
decision to go ahead
and decide to make zero charisma OOP
well that was actually when we were here
in I guess 2009 when best worst movie
was at South by Southwest was our first
time in austin and we really liked the
town a lot we had a great time and
invest first movie was kind of a little
bit of a sleeper I'll say hit at South
by Southwest but it was a movie that I
think people were kind of not paying
much attention to and then the
screenings it very very well and by the
end of the week it was kind of being
talked about and we were it was very
exciting for us and we kind of thought
you know well gonna do this again yeah I
mean it was basically basically seeing
the crowd see best worst movie seen in
the theater and getting that audience
reaction I mean it was like we do this
again really soon as we can so and and
we just felt like we learned a lot of
stuff along with you to the three of us
hating myself in the director Michael
Paul Stevens and we learned so much
about you know narrative and characters
stuff that's not specific to
documentaries and we just suddenly this
idea that we had had we suddenly felt
like that would that would make a really
good movie and they think we could sort
of make people laugh and move them at
the same time just like with best movie
and so let's let's do it mm-hmm you know
and when we first watched the teaser
trailer that you have on any gogo
campaign I mean you watch this thing it
looks as if you guys have already shot
the entire movie and I'm guessing that
you guys literally just shot the trailer
are you guys going to keep that foot is
that kind of is that for the film or are
you guys just going to reshoot the
entire thing we're going to reshape the
entire thing yeah that was some uh just
technically we were using the cameras
that we want to use yeah that's nice
footage um probably the sound is not as
good yeah yeah i mean the group was just
you know is andrew ryan Thomas yeah
Amanda's producing that's men you know
that was it it was just us three key so
hopefully we'll have four out
because I have an experience that it
looks great but we do want it to you
know look even better you know the
locations that we use were spectacular
but you know some of the locations like
where they actually play them to dragons
that was just somebody that's condo that
we paid them to use their living room
and dining room just like upstairs to
let us have this for free out for four
hours and you know and we have about an
hour to sort of decorate it set it up
fake pissed off the wall and put ours up
but I mean you know art direction is
really important to us I want to really
have locations that just scream that
this is a real place yeah and yeah
especially the grandmother's house I
mean this has to look like this is
grandmother so yeah so there's a lot
more work we want to put into the visual
aspect and again with those the actors
were expect hackulo but made no
rehearsal it was / okay now you're going
to say this and agreed to say this no
and they would just do it once or twice
and then we move on so people that lets
wonder how much prep time did you guys
put in see there wasn't a lot of prep
time out how much time do the actors
have to sort of get into the into their
characters and i guess i should add are
these the same actors that we're going
to see in the film i think some of them
will end up being but it's it's kind of
hard to say right now could mean you
know until we actually have the money
and have you know investors and
executive producers on board it's we
really kind of don't happy ability to
say anything definite about casting but
we certainly do you know ask those
actors to be in teaser because we
thought you know they were right for the
parts and so it's it's we're still
wondering what's gonna happen in terms
of that and and in terms of them having
they had no rehearsal time at all I mean
it was basically they just here's a
scrub Eric I mean you know we gave them
the script maybe a day or two before but
we didn't go over it with them yeah yeah
which we really like to do look a lot of
them Davis getting rid the whole strip
they're just like yeah okay I don't know
their likes what it's been we stand over
here at see the line
no I what am i doing now is it correct
that you were somewhat uncomfortable
with launching this IndieGoGo campaign
and if so what were your reservations I
was just afraid we wouldn't make the
money really I wasn't I wasn't afraid to
do that any gogo campaign it was just
you know what if we don't raise them on
if we don't raise the money if that
embarrassing i don't know like women's i
don't know i mean i was just like how do
we do it you know cuz we went two panels
itself by Southwest this year and they
told us about this crowdfunding thing
and I'm kind of heard of it before and
so what do they were like you have to be
very focused when you do it you can't
just put it up and just hold people's
home and and we're like okay so when we
did it was like okay we've got to be
very focused with this I've gotta know I
had to make a vlog and you know we had
to you know notify our contacts and all
that kind of stuff kind of get the ball
rolling but I mean from there it's just
it the thing we didn't expect is so many
people that we didn't know right donate
so much money I mean I thought that's
what's really well that's what I intend
to tell you what the South by Southwest
panels was you know most of the money
that you get is going to come from
friends and family and these websites
just serve as a place where they can all
go to donate money don't expect too many
strangers to be giving you money and so
our concert was do we have enough
friends yeah that one this thing yeah
but then turn out that you know I think
so many five percent of the money came
from people we don't know I mean yeah
it's just staggering to think that
somebody in Australia who has never met
you saw the snake and then gave you a
hundred dollars no kidding a thousand
dollars and you're like how can you like
one that's amazing to me and so now the
fear is like you know you feel like you
have an obligation to these people these
hundreds of people giving you money and
like we've got to deliver something I'm
sure we're gonna have this you know
completed this year but you know you
want to deliver something that meets
their expectations but at the same time
you don't want to do that you want to
stick to what your vision is so it's
yeah it's complicated well I mean you
guys are being really modest with sort
of just pieces
together this teaser trailer you know
it's something that is engaging you know
and when we watch and I can feel a
connection with what you have the
writing the characters and and you know
and when I saw it I was sort of
compelled like you know what this just
looks like something that I want to
support so it it certainly has that sort
of aura or magic to it so I just wanted
something that's important too sure that
isn't I'm sorry oh I'm sorry go ahead go
ahead and I'll come back with a question
yeah that was great about the teaser
trailer having that because one of the
big concerns on IndieGoGo is that people
want to know that there actually is
going to be something made like the
first thing they learn know before they
donate it is this actually going to get
made and so if we had something that
made people feel very secure that there
was a film behind it you know we've seen
more success stories on Kickstarter you
know we've seen larger mounts raised on
Kickstarter why did you guys decide to
go with IndieGoGo between the two um I
don't know it was it was close we were
we were going back and forth and I guess
we kind of and I may be totally wrong
about this it's just our impression was
that IndieGoGo seem to be more more only
film Kickstarter was like a lot of
products and like technological
innovations you know people like
inventing they're trying to raise money
to invent a new product or new piece of
software IndieGoGo seem to be far more
about more weighted towards artistic
never sore gone also i think another
thing is that you know if you don't make
your soul on kickstarter you don't get
the money and I was like well we're not
meeting our goal probably I guess I'm a
custom it's so it sounds like well
that's true better yeah yeah so that
sounds an element that is yeah that does
make you go yeah let's do the one where
we know we'll at least get something
yeah because it's a lot of work I mean
that's why I it's a little confusing to
me about pixar because you know
is a lot of work to kind of have a
campaign and try to get people
interested in to life you make ten
thousand dollars and if your goals
twelve thousand dollars you don't make
it I mean you know get that money that's
that's a lot of work at time and I you
know I don't that's kind of that doesn't
really make sense to me yes but they say
that that encourages people to do it so
I'm right now you were both quote
unquote warned at South by Southwest
that it takes a lot of energy and effort
to to you know get this campaign up and
running how do you feel k that your vlog
audience help to to translate into such
a success that you've had already I mean
do you think that if you hadn't had that
built-in audience already that it would
be where it is now I mean you guys have
just done an amazing job and it is a
very hard thing to do to crowdfund and
you've made it look very easy do you
think that that built-in vlog audience
just really carried you through um I I
think it helped I mean I think probably
from my people from YouTube I think that
was probably about two thousand dollars
of the money which is incredible but
it's not you know it didn't help I also
feel like those people are connected
online I think that's probably where its
most powerful but youtube is just this
connection online you know it's like
because of my youtube because of my
blogging pass I know I also know kind of
how it works like how much pressure you
put on people how you know how much you
know people can get really no angle to
line with wanting things and too much
almost fan people too much I'm very
sensitive to that I feel like from
YouTube um you know I think also from
the youtube thing I have a lot of
Twitter followers and that helps
obviously and spreads the word on that
it is being modest right now too because
she's YouTube has offered her the
partner program many times that she's
never taken in violence because and then
she's never liked asked anybody for
money or any of her subscribers for
money so it was a big kind of issue for
her to finally go to her subscribers and
say give me money for the first time
I've never ever
right you know and even then after you
know even though some people on YouTube
are constantly asking for money she
still gets comments like why don't you
get a job you know I I just want to ask
enjoy but what is your take on Katie's
Katie's vlog how do you react to
everything there you know what's your
view but I have not seen it yet no it's
great I mean she did it I think of Katie
as being such an artist of integrity
throughout this whole YouTube thing when
you know she was sort of in at the
ground floor when it was when it was a
just catching on sort of been getting
big before anybody was making money on
it and then when a lot of youtubers
started trying to like cash in on you
know just end with that's fine I mean
that's what if that's your career
basically you know trying to make make a
living doing YouTube but it would it
became sort of this for money thing I
don't know Katie sort of just resisted
that in a big way and and and we're sort
of reaping the benefits of that now
because yeah her subscribers have been
so sort of loyal to her you know not
putting ads on her page and not uh you
know trying to raise money on time yeah
I am and so that's sort of integrity and
so I have a lot of respect and they're
really really funny too and also yeah
and when you live with someone the last
thing you can want to do is watch their
video I mean you know it thank you you
know a coming back coming back to your
crowdfunding campaign who was the first
person or who were the first people that
you shared this idea with it and how do
they respond you mean a donors or just
you know me you know maybe just anyone
you bounce the idea off oh but you know
literally when you had this idea of what
we're going to do this who are the
people you turn to first but um gosh
well I mean one big person is Michael
Paul Stephenson the director
best movie and he's been a lot of along
with help and support and he's actually
right now you know looking towards his
next film that he's directing called
destroyed which you can see it is it
destroyed the movie mom I think it's
under Maddox down matters tone
productions if you look at under destroy
it's a it's a horror comedy that he's
producing but he's so he's but he's been
helping us in a lot of other respects
and has always been very supportive a
lot of people actually when you
explained the movie they would just kind
of I don't know they they wouldn't mean
they were like that sounds great and
we've got D&D people they're just like
and that's why I felt like we had to
make the teaser trailer because he felt
like that would communicate it better I
think cuz we got a script you know and
you can tell you can say like read the
script and and you know this is the
ideas what we're doing and really people
want to see something that's the best
way to get people excited as to show
them something three minutes or under
but I leave my nice week and I swear
this experience has taught me that if
you have an idea for something and if
everybody you tell that idea to gets it
then it's not original enough it's not
unique enough you know as from this
point on I want to be able to if I have
an idea I want some people to kind of go
why would you do that the hell are you
talking about my magenta then that means
it's you know it's been done already
properly well now that you've exceeded
your goal and you still have eight days
left do you almost wish you instead a
higher goal I think times and I think
everything is good the way that's your
over not going no I mean right now we
just have a bowl in our mind of 25,000
or like that would be amazing if we hit
that on good it's already been amazing
so it's like we've surpassed everything
they expect it but now we're like okay
what if we hit 25,000 it could happen
and I just kind of like to keep that
mental goal whether it happens or not
but you know it just be a nice round
number to tell people and kind of you
know for other
Fester's right to see that and the
15,000 was great goal I think because
that's the upper end that people on
IndieGoGo are asking for films and the
fact that we surpassed it by like you
know sixty percent or something that's a
great thing to be able to say like we
said it a high goal and we just blew it
away so that's worth that it's worth
that to be able to say that um you know
and and what outlets are helping you
guys um you know how was the word spread
so fast on this and I guess while we say
that we should give a shout out to Lord
Bronco on Twitter he's the one that
reached out to us and said hey you know
you really need to get in touch with the
folks behind 0 ther is mo so if you're
wondering though we found out about it a
gentleman named Lord Bronco on Twitter
but but how is the word spreading like
what what outlets are sort of embracing
this and pushing this out it was a big
ones though the first ones that came
along were uh examiner com cobbler for
example com contacted us and want to do
an interview who was a fan of desperate
movie as well Oh God tion once the
probably the first article right yeah a
badass digest which is some sort of blog
it's a local austin movie blog and then
from there i guess it was through them
that it got to wire and then I 09 Boing
Boing OH kotaku picked it up to and when
that started happening we were just like
like what was going on and who did you
reach out to first how did these people
to did were you initially but all those
ever what was dazing about it that we
didn't we didn't we didn't check out it
yeah honestly we were thinking we've
been we had been planning with one the
when you know halfway through what will
the campaign what were these a press
release or something but we weren't
expecting anybody be interested in it is
just something you sort of do and then
all these you know outlets were
contacting us we have her like we don't
really need to decide we didn't need to
do a press release I guess at that point
which is what's
so amazing and I know that you know
that's we're very lucky to have that but
yeah to have the outlets like contacting
you about something you know and that's
the value of having a video for for
IndieGoGo campaign like it not just a
video hello this is who I am is what I'm
doing but I like something that people
would want hey check this out i want you
to see this video and would pass it
around you know that's huge and i would
recommend anybody who's doing any digo
campaign to have some kind of fun bigger
watch something that's fun that sounds
really exciting that to sort of have
your audience you know these different
sort of indie champions you know grab
grab ahold of what you have and help you
spread the word that has to be really
exciting you know and i guess here here
we are on the other side they scare it
together oh sorry so katie i'm curious
how do you worry about crowdfunding now
you had sort of a some reservations
going in you weren't sure if you could
make the goal how do you feel about it
now we think it's great I mean it's
amazing you know yeah we uh I mean I
recommend it to everybody sorry yeah
good we recommend it everybody i mean
it's it's really the way to go i
recommend doing a video and and i think
that's the best way to gain excitement I
mean just waste from our experience you
know and I'll short and sweet and and
I'm very curious to see what happens
with crowdfunding in the future because
it's still in sort of its infancy and I
know that's part of the reason why you
know a lot of big outlets were were
interested in our project work because
oh here's a successful crowdfunding
campaign and people are starting to
wonder what this thing is you know and
the more attention crowd funding gets
that it won't be able to it will have to
change in some way so I don't know how
that's going to change I hope it doesn't
become something where it's just people
are trying to use it just to advertise
or you know I I don't I really am
curious what the future of crowd funding
will be you know so now I swear after
since we've been doing this it seems
like everybody we know has a Kickstarter
yeah I think we know like
least five people that have like or have
campaigns going or have been going since
we've been doing it you know or just
kind of weird whenever for the future of
crowdfunding like if everybody has one
then I think right let's let you be less
likely to donate when everybody you know
has got one then you can't so I just
don't know what the future of its gonna
be interesting yeah i think that touches
on which which your guys raised earlier
in terms of you know with social
networks and with the internet and wait
in the way we all sort of are connected
there the way we support one another
there I don't interact on on Facebook
and Twitter and such and it's sort of
like how often do you turn the people
and say okay I have this project I need
I need your financial support like how
often do you go to the well and that's
sort of like what you're saying with
with Katie's blog it's like you know she
would just give away this this blog and
then people just enjoy and be
entertained by it and yet she hadn't she
hadn't gone to them for it for any
specific like financial reason um so I
think that sort of does become a
question you know how often do you do
that I think the answer is not very
often you can't somebody somebody else
is that is advice they said you can do
this once yeah the next time you might
make a movie people aren't gonna give
you mother you can't do this for every
one of your movies so make sure that one
is good so you guys don't plan on
jumping into the fray anytime soon that
you're just gonna do this one campaign
ride this out and I mean do you have any
thoughts of like hey you know we could
have done this better we can improve
this and we can raise this with this
much more money oh you know sure you
think of that stuff but then you also
know that you know a lot of donations
that came from people who believe in
what we're doing but let's say if we
make the movie and it's not that great
you know then you're not going to think
those people are not going to be there
for you you maybe could raise money on
the next project but it wouldn't be
nearly as much I wouldn't imagine right
I yeah I don't at least your family and
friends they're gonna ok you want to
start you want to make your own movie
here's your money but yeah oh you want
to make another one well well
on your own yeah and Katie you mentioned
that you are sensitive to people who
sort of span your wall or or you know
hit you up for things or send out
promotional blast how often do you think
someone should go to their quote unquote
fan base with requests or spreading of
news what do you think is the
appropriate way to do it without sort of
us alienating them um I will like I'm
right now I'm dealing with Facebook page
I've kind of you know post on there and
i'm posting thank yous and stuff every
time someone donates i'll put you know
we'll all grab a list of people who
donated and put it on the Facebook page
but it's you know I think ah I mean
something like every three days you know
what I mean you don't wanna you know
what about our people basically no one
wants to be bombarded with you know
other people suck they will want to be
aware of it and they can keep track of
it as much as they want to but no one
loves people part and I think um yeah so
I think it's just did be cautious and we
have you know we haven't even started
production yet so we're thinking like
these people who we have their
information on facebook or generous
enough to like our Facebook page we want
to carry them through all the way to the
end distribution you know we don't want
to lose these people's enthusiasm and so
you know it's like overexposure you know
you know oversaturation you won't even
on small-scale tiny micro budget
projects you want to avoid that you know
I mean to bring up distribution there
Andrew and maybe this questions a little
bit too far out but but you know what
we're seeing on the indie level on the
micro level of the importance of
thinking ahead to distribution you know
of how you're going to take this film
and how you're going to reach your
audience so even though you guys aren't
in into production yet are you are you
sure they're circulating those ideas are
you thinking about like how are we going
to give this to our audience sure yeah I
mean just to make a business plan to you
know present to possible investors and
producers you have to have shown that
you
thought about distribution and in that
sense you know it's probably a very
similar to what most and films are
looking for distribution there's always
that you know ultimate goal of the
actual you know but you have to be
realistic that that's very rarely
achieve high small-time films what we do
have that's really fortunate is we do
have a relationship with you know
michael stevenson and managed on
productions which did a source semi self
distribution a best worst movie in which
in that model that he that he knows
really well you know we do have that as
a possibility was relationships with all
of the art house cinemas across the
country that best works will be played
in you know and even DVD is a weird
thing because you know i mean how much
longer does that have yeah and as a you
plan ahead for DVD but you know you know
that video on man is probably the most
likely way that people will be watching
movies in just in a couple years hmm so
so what's the official love and dated
the campaign the time and date hi I
think it's next Monday which is june six
yes I think it's june six it I'm not
sure exactly what time the times come
strange look in the goal of the day or
something I think it's like a new
dancers okay well we start with but it's
for some reason the days click over and
yeah okay so we'll see ok ok we're going
to include the sort of a link you know
that'll be attached to this video so
anyone that wants to see and I think we
both certainly highly recommend we're
gonna be sending as many people over to
see the teaser trailer you guys have you
know you know we love an excellent and
we want you guys to stay in touch with
us and keep us updated oh ok keep us
updated on your progress um you know we
really want to see what you guys do with
this film and you know we wanted the
other chat with you again when you're
all the way through the process that'd
be great yes thank you so much oh yeah
it's very helpful yeah I think thank you
for sitting down in China
with us here on Memorial Day cards
anyway but that's Katie Graham everybody
in andrew matthews of zero charisma
charisma thank you right thanks guys
thank you